i think we're we're headed down to
really i think 2022 uh i i mean i'm
saying this a couple week or two ago i'm
like you guys i hope you're ready for
how insane it's going to be you don't
get it look
my my segment i did at 4 pm was about
how
they're trying to disqualify donald
trump so he can't run for office they've
been trying to disqualify him and
they're also mark elias a democrat
lawyer says that he believes mid this
year you're going to see
disqualifications of republicans running
for office they know they can't win
against the trump populists the america
first nationalists so what they're going
to do is they're going to use january 6
to claim
section 3 of the 14th amendment was
violated and then make it so that
marjorie taylor green donald trump and
other populist republicans
will not have their names appear on the
ballots and will be ineligible to hold
office this is the direction things are
going that is insane
we're going to see smear campaigns
the harassment is going to be intense
this is it's january 7th day and we're
here talking about the aftermath of us
getting swatted seriously 2022 is going
to be nuts 20 2018 was the democrats
being like okay we're gonna we're gonna
take back the house and they did and we
all complained and we're like wow i
guess we didn't see that coming then
2019 you get the presidential primaries
2020 was in was really nuts
2020 was insane the writhing the
hundred-day sieges on cities it was
probably the craziest year of my life
yes it was easily yeah yeah and then
2021 everyone's kind of burned out
there's no big elections
now we're getting into 2022 which is
republicans have a real chance to take
back the house and the senate and
displace the establishment's authority
because trump controls the republican
party you got people like ted cruz that
would love to pull it back to
establishment they can't do as much as
they try and pretend they're not
this is where they're gonna pull out all
the stops
if you if you think that the shadow
campaign to fortify the election was bad
take a look at them overtly tweeting we
will straight up just say
your politician can't be in office they
will literally just decree that
so this is that's beyond elections
this is this is
civil war but this is a sign of panic on
there and i mean this is a tell right so
is this a good thing or a bad thing
yeah it's a good point actually it's a
good question it it it may be
that they're so they're so desperate
they know they're going to lose that the
only thing they have left in their
arsenal is overt cheating
and what i mean by that is using law
fair political law fair to disqualify
your opponent instead of actually
running against them right that may be
that may be a positive a good good news
that that if people go out and vote in
the primaries and uh uh primary these
neocon and established republicans get
in some america first populists who are
just there for the working class want to
bring factories back and secure our
borders they'll probably win
and that
i think is why they're going so hard
against anybody who opposes the machine
because the traditional methods aren't
working for them anymore people are
breaking through the lies the narrative
isn't working well there's a lot of
things that play here specifically with
covid and especially what happened in
south africa with many medical
professionals saying that this is going
to happen here in the united states and
that soon we might be experiencing the
end of this pandemic and historically
speaking newsweek actually talked about
this yesterday they talked about how at
the end of pandemics throughout human
history usually this leads to a lot of
civil unrest so i think this is also a
big possibility
it routinely does happen it historically
does happen but also financially there's
a lot of things happening that people
are still not aware of usually economic
trends take a long time to kind of
surface and really affect people they're
not
imminent they usually take months uh to
fully affect individuals so i think
we're going to be feeling the full
ramification of hyper money printing so
there's a lot of things at play here
that create a lot of instability and
with all of this instability i think
it's very fair to say that we're in for
a rough ride not just politically not
just with this larger divide and conquer
agenda the left versus the right but
there's a lot of other circumstances i
would say accident accident
exigent circumstances that are leading
to of course the probability of some
major troubles ahead i'm gonna get luke
a dictionary for his birthday yeah yes
and then like whenever he has the word
we'll like we'll pull it up and be like
no he can write his own dictionary
actually that's right
i couldn't make my own i wanted
that's actually a really good idea no no
for real though to make like a t-shirt
with all of the words yeah like luke's
words exacerbate oh that would be
awesome like one of those like where you
got to circle the word and the big maze
of letters
or like what's the puzzle thing where
you have to circle like a word
search
word search how did you guys know what a
word search is they didn't know the word
for words dude i think in different ways
than your average man hey i've been i've
been looking at um the crypto market it
is getting smeared what you were saying
was making me think about it and i don't
know how related it is but it looks like
there's a coordinated move to smear the
market
uh drive the prices no no no no no huge
so the the civil unrest in kazakhstan
shut down a major uh mining operation
interesting so this caused huge price
fluctuations and things like that and
they might be using that as an excuse to
drive the market down well no i think
people are going to exploit it seeing it
coming but i think this is just all that
you know kazakhstan crypto what's
happening um i mean us getting swatted
what's happening with um
trying to disqualify trump yo the global
system whatever it is is falling apart
so it's funny that you get someone like
alex jones he mentions the globalists
and they're planning all that stuff and
i'm kind of i'm like looking around the
world and i'm like maybe that plan ain't
working you know whatever what i i don't
agree with alex on a good majority of
what he believes about the globalists
but it is a fact that there are global
elites that work that coordinate
obviously they do trade negotiations and
deals and everything and they have an
idea of how the system is supposed to be
working but it's not well no no no but
this is what i kind of want to add here
because this is order out of chaos they
create the chaos and out of the chaos
out of the panic out of the suffering
out of the fighting they create a new
system that people naturally go to
because they already have it in play and
it's going to be their solution to the
problems that they caused that's how i
personally see it that's for that's my
opinion especially understanding how
they previously worked before especially
seeing their writings especially seeing
just just how brazen they are with it
especially with the world economic forum
and the documents that they release
bragging about what they want to do and
if you think of a way of how are you
going to usurp people's sovereignty how
are you going to take away their
financial mobility how are you going to
subjugate them in almost every aspect of
their existence well you make their
existence right now unbearable so they
come into your system begging to be
under of course your new world order
that they're conveniently building that
works in their favor even more so that's
how i see it from from my perspective
you know what's really crazy is this
conspiracy theory that donald trump
wasn't supposed to win
and because he did it forced the
establishment to speed up their timeline
yes so basically this is the conspiracy
i'm not saying it's true okay i'm just
saying this is you know the conspiracy
chatter that hillary was supposed to win
in 2016 and they were supposed to slowly
be pushing out a lot of these draconian
policies over four years instead trump
wins they panic and don't know how to
stop him because trump was changing
things back in favor of america which
was rewinding the clock on the
establishment plan
so then finally in the last year they
had to do everything they wanted to do
in a span in four years but in in like
six seven months
so everything got crammed and everybody
could see it happening because you can
only move people so far so fast so that
then the idea is that
now they're trying to get back on track
with it but too many people were shocked
by this disruption in the system
if hillary had won
and then they started doing like look in
2018 is when they changed the definition
of anti-vaxxer to someone who opposes
government mandates again i'm not saying
this is true i'm saying these are what
people are are asserting as to why they
believe the establishment had a plan for
draconian lockdowns they very clearly
wanted to sign the trans-pacific
partnership and get cheap oil out of
malaysia in australia if you give aid
and comfort to people who don't like the
mandates you're deemed an anti-vaxxer
according to the government officials in
australia that have decreed it that's an
absolute lunacy they're changing
definitions by the day they're confusing
people as much as they can and they're
trying to create a panic they're trying
to create a fight they're trying to
create something that of course will
make us not realize what's really
happening to the general public because
that's the only way they could get away
with their bigger power grabs that
they're uh conducting right now yeah the
um the trans-pacific partnership had a
clause called the investor state dispute
settlement clause that gave corporations
like malaysian corporations the power to
sue the american government if the
american people were discriminating
in quotes against them by not buying
their oil so if we chose opt out of
exxon's malaysian oil production they're
going to sue us they're going to sue the
the citizens and trump buried that he
said no i'm not signing it trash it but
hillary was about to sign it
um and that's obama wanted to set back a
lot of the plans for it's not about this
this illuminati it's not about the cabal
it's about one guy who works for an oil
company who's sitting there going
they're going to do this tpp thing this
is great news for us tell the investors
then trump gets in and they're like god
you know what man he just screwed us
over yeah and then what happens is you
don't
you don't need grand conspiracies for
these things to happen you need a small
handful of ultra wealthy elites birds of
a feather flocked together they're not
colluding or coordinating in some grand
conspiracy they have similar interests
because they're leaders of industry and
free trade agreements benefit their
companies we can send more factories
overseas when trump did that he pissed
them off at the same time all of a
sudden they're donating money to super
pacs against trump it looks coordinated
but it's actually called a standalone
complex now it's conspiracies exist too
don't get me wrong i mean there could be
a guy to oil company and he calls up his
other body at oil company and he's like
hey we're getting screwed over here you
know let's lobby against this right so
things like that could absolutely happen
but you got it you got to admit when
trump got in
smashing the tpp that was like kicking
the balls of all these big international
corporations well some people are
arguing that obama wasn't going to sign
it anyway that's the art counter
argument to of course that claim i see
it a little bit differently but i
understand exactly where you're coming
from because
and we don't even have to argue about
this because whether your case is true
or my case is true whether it's it's
people looking out for their interests
or people colluding together and working
together it doesn't matter the important
fact to all agree on here is that
they're doing it and because they're
doing it this is screwing the average
american over it's giving them
less freedom it's giving them less
economic opportunities it's giving them
less prosperity and sovereignty and
that's a serious issue that is getting
completely out of hand especially in our
current way of life that is being
threatened by a lot of these globalists
that are taking advantage of this
tragedy for their own personal benefits
so i don't even want to argue i see a
little bit differently but they're doing
it and we need to realize that before
it's too late the end result
can't go into a building without your
app
you've got to scan it it tracks every
place you go you use it for everything
it's going to be for your you know
buying stuff i've already i've already
got on my phone the the near field
communications you know wallet you just
tap your phone to the thing that's crazy
then they're gonna now they're doing the
vax passports everywhere cook county the
second largest county in the united
states has a vaccine mandate this is not
one city this is like dozens of cities a
big city like chicago and then all of
these smaller suburbs are all under this
mandate a few of these suburbs have said
screw you we will not enforce this and
some of them are just ignoring it out
right but this is i couldn't believe
when i heard that cook county this is
this is the county that surrounds
chicago in the chicagoland area that's
crazy to me so your future is going to
be you don't got your phone on you or
your battery died can't come in sorry
you're not being tracked in your in your
with your tracking device sorry you
haven't given us all of your data so we
know where where and when you poop too
bad that's something that sounds
discriminatory against people that don't
have electricity
yeah yeah
yeah they'll they'll then then you'll
get the left argument they'll be like
the left will come out and say obama
phones yeah no they'll say they'll say
it's not it's not discriminatory it's
just that we have to give everyone free
phones that's what they'll end up saying
let's preload some software on there and
traffic yeah
so this is inevitable there's no way
really to avoid it at this point
no no no no i mean know you brought it
up earlier i think they're desperate
uh look i don't know if there was a
grand plan for any of this like that i
was just saying like people believe
there's a grand plan for this it's it's
certainly true that they they are
working towards this now but i think
it's less
this like overarching conspiracy among a
global elite group like alex jones might
say and more so some democrats went to
china saw how how
their totalitarian communist party
system works and and want that for
themselves it's clearly not a an
all-encompassing conspiracy because you
have people like ron desantis you have
people like donald trump people like
donald trump clearly disagrees with a
lot of his own supporters they even boo
him sometimes but he's certainly not in
line with other establishment elites
i think you have a lot of wealthy
individuals that lean democratic that
want a communist chinese communist party
style system in here and they're working
towards it and then you have other
billionaires you have the koch brothers
that
not necessarily involved in that but
maybe a little bit in some ways then you
have the mercers who oppose it so it's
not like all the ultra elites are all in
line together it's just very powerful
people with aligned interests will align
their interests not through a conspiracy
necessarily but just by doing similar
things and there's very few of them
davos
you could see it but not you know
criminal to be honest from my
perspective no i i hear you're saying
i'll put it this way
the the typically the idea that makes
people believe it's impossible is like
there's ten cabal members they have a
secret meeting where they come to the
table and they say how can we control
the world and they're like
and they write down in their secret book
and they turn up my shadow typically
when and then there's like occult
ceremonies and mock child sacrifices and
a whole bunch of other stuff sorry go on
no but my point is often these meetings
would seem
banal right you'd see a guy in a suit
walk up to another guy and be like i
haven't seen you in a few months so look
we're gonna be doing a big export from
california to china but we need this tpp
man and they're gonna be like don't
worry we'll take care of it for you
we're going to put a bunch of money into
this super pac and so if if a regular
person saw the meeting they'd be like
what's wrong with that it's just a
business meeting among you know people
running companies but when they have
look i'll tell you i'll put it this way
if i were to tell you that a large group
of ultra wealthy billionaire elites and
princes and kings and politicians were
meeting to discuss how they were going
to control oil around the world would
you call that a conspiracy in fact they
have these meetings all the time they
are just like oil gas expo in libya and
then all of the big companies show up
and they walk in and get their name
badge and they walk around shaking hands
uh jim yeah with exxon nice to meet you
and they sign up the forums like well
if a regular person saw these things
they would not think it's a conspiracy
when i was in when i was in brazil i
went to a weapons expo there were
generals there were you know high
ranking military officials pilots there
were politicians i watched one guy
walking with a bunch of bodyguards like
you know in suits and they're armed
it's not a conspiracy
it's a convention but all of these
government elites are there colluding on
the best weapons for suppressing dissent
now if i told you princes kings world
leaders and billionaires were meeting to
discuss the production of weapons to
suppress dissent around the world people
would be like that's a crazy conspiracy
it was a convention it was called uh the
latin american aerospace defense
convention or something like i went
there and walked around and i saw all of
these people there having meetings
having lunch cracking open champagne
that's that's the conspiracy that's
happening in plain sight but regular
people when they hear this they think
it's impossible because they imagine it
like a creepy cabal underground going
instead of business well to be fair
there is an aspect of it and for the
average person hearing it they're kind
of like wait what's going on here and
for some people it scares them away for
some people it's like okay wait wait
wait let's really look into this and it
kind of awakens them so there's
different strategies out there but when
you look into stuff like the bohemian
grove and and spirit cooking and
literally very powerful people taking
blood and writing uh messages on the
walls with human excrement and and other
feces and other horrible things to talk
with interdimensional species that's a
bunch of weird stuff that has been
documented has has been happening going
along with a lot of powerful people so
there is an element of that but it loses
some people and some people are like
wait that's too crazy i can't believe
that and it shatters their world view
and automatically they kind of shut off
and they put up their blinders some
people though are like wait probably
with the way my life's been going with
the with the way i've been screwed over
with taxes with the way i've been
screwed over by my boss and have having
this horrible office job and been
grinding through this entire machine
probably but so there's two perspectives
um and i think both are relevant i think
when it comes to discussing powerful
interests global elites
bankers military and stuff when you get
into the weird occult stuff that a lot
of them do that's when you'll lose
regular people
because i i don't think it's look if you
come to me and you're like did you know
that these you know powerful elites meet
in a place called bohemian grove or
whatever i'd be like bro i have no idea
what that has to do with my life and why
i can't get a good job that pays me well
but if you go and say did you know the
government printed something like 40 of
all u.s dollars in the past year which
has devalued your purchasing power i'll
put it this way because of what the fed
has done and what the gut what the
politicians have done
all the money in your bank account was
cut in half and people are going to be
like what why how what that speaks to
people and then you can start getting
into here's why they do it here's what
they've been doing and here's a book
about a place called jekyll island and
then sometimes people like gillane come
across that are so reprehensible that
people care about their weirdness
how amazing that they were like we're
going to charge her with trafficking can
victor have trafficking to no one that's
it she was she was convicted of
trafficking children
to no one yeah she was running an
illegal business with a lot of customers
the customers who participated in this
legal business who paid for her to be a
part of this illegal business who made
this illegal business possible no no
look look
that must be wrong if if there were
people who were engaged in this business
with her and paying her to do it
certainly they would have been
criminally charged and prosecuted right
and considering they haven't been she
must have just been standing there
offering up trafficking people and then
they arrested her for it there certainly
must have been no real customers to what
her and epstein were doing yeah no
powerful clients at
makes a good point when you want to talk
to people about really how crazy things
get eventually you will get a story like
epstein where it's it's true we know
it's true the evidence is out and they
even convicted elaine she's guilty and
now people are like what about the rest
of them all the people who are flying on
that plane and going there and then you
can be like conspiracies do happen and
here's one so i'll tell you this if i'm
i'm not a big fan of most conspiracies
because a lot of people connect dots
that shouldn't be connected that's the
problem however if there is ever
something you truly believe and
someone's a skeptic you can just be like
i may be wrong
but epstein
that's a good point like maybe i should
you know consider i don't know
everything the klaus schwab thing is
kind of i don't even know if there's
does he even land in a conspiracy world
right now he's absolutely blatantly said
he wants to create a corporate
government collusive yeah that's a form
of global governance he's worth 0.95
million dollar klaus schwab his net
worth is under a million dollars he's
the head of the economic forum leading
the global change in global economics
and he's supposedly worth less than a
million dollars according to the ceo
ian there's a lot of money laundering
and the people who have a lot of money
are not on the forbes top money list
right they hide it in assets they hide
it in stocks they hide it in commodities
they're able to of course transfer their
wealth in ways that of course are not
seen thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time